bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction voici les titres de ce 10
juillet dans quatre jours la plus belle
avenue du monde accueillera des
militaires pour le défilé de la fête
nationale c'est à satory dans les
yvelines que se déroulent les
répétitions célébration du 14 juillet
toujours avec le concert qui se prépare
lui sur le champ de mars et c'est une
société be no âge qui se charge de sa
mise en place technique nous avons suivi
son directeur sur le terrain à part et
puis début de vacances plus vieux mais
heureux à magny les hameaux l'opération
remettait tongs rencontre le succès
ateliers sportifs préparation d'un
carnaval
bon bien sûr le retour du soleil les
départements de la petite couronne dont
les yvelines fêtent leurs 50 ans
aujourd'hui le 10 juillet 1964 le
général de gaulle lançait la
réorganisation de la région parisienne
devant l'étalement urbain
l'industrialisation à la forte
augmentation de la population les
services administratifs des seuls
préfecture de paris et de versailles ne
pouvait plus répondre aux démarches les
nouveaux départements n'ont cependant
été créés que le 1er janvier 1968 après
la nomination des préfets et l'élection
en 67 également des nouveaux conseils
généraux à 81 ans un jean ridel
cyclistes licenciés au club dini
palaiseau va tenter ce jeudi soir dès
19h d'établir un nouveau record de
l'heure en catégorie seniors de plus de
80 ans sur la piste du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le normand d'origine se prépare depuis
cinq mois il bat régulièrement à
l'entraînement
le record actuel de 30,5 km nous l'avons
rencontré à son arrivée au vélodrome il
se dit très inspiré par l'exploit
réalisé par robert marchand 103 ans il y
a quelques semaines et c'était aussi au
vélodrome on les écoute donc au micro
d'olivier maniscalco et d'élodie mois
comme monsieur robert marchand à son
deux ans et mis en piste pour établir un
record sans leur accord si elle n'a pas
d'autre et moi qu'est ce que j'ai fait
après j'ai dit bien il doit bien y avoir
à un record de 91 ans la préparation aux
deux fois par semaine surtout le
vendredi où
on essaye de faire le record tous les
vendredis il n'y a pas de raison que ça
passe pas mais bon on sait pas vous
savez ça fait soixante quatre ans que je
suis sur le vélo j'en ai eu des fois
j'étais confiant puis je faisais dernier
mais cet exploit il va donc le réaliser
ce jeudi soir entre 19 et 20 heures nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler dans nos
prochaines éditions nous ouvrons à
présent une page dédiée au 14 juillet et
le traditionnel défilé qui nous
intéresse tout d'abord elle est dernière
répétition avant les champs-elysées se
déroule en ce moment sur la base
militaire de satory l'occasion pour nous
de rencontrer des élèves officiers de
l'école de la gendarmerie nationale ils
défilent pour la première fois un
reportage de catherine château lyonnaise
est clair qu'en bien l'école deux opus
sur la gendarmerie nationale alors
comment objet
stoïque sous la pluie ces élèves de
l'école des officiers de la gendarmerie
répètent leur dernier mouvement leurs
derniers pas un pas précis et bien
évidemment coordonner le 14 juillet
défileront sur les champs elysées sur
une distance précise de 800 m en ce
mercredi pluvieux ses élèves officiers
se trouve à satory pour une répétition
générale avec les autres corps militaire
quand vous voyez les défilés à la télé
non j'imagine est pas le travail qui
peut y avoir derrière c'est sûr on a
l'impression que c'est facile d'avoir
tout le monde bien aligné avec les mains
qui qui arrive au même moment au même
endroit et c'est tout bien tout bien
propre et puis en fait c'est beaucoup de
travail parce que
chaque individu en fait on peut tout
faire sur tout chambouler à tout moment
et donc vraiment très concentré
c'est du détail ça je sais pas si ça se
voit pour vinci mais c'est vrai que
énormément de choses à penser
le port de tête 9 fourreau donc se
comporte
voilà c'est du détail c'est très
minutieux mais ça fait toute la
différence à tout défier au début de
l'année quand on commence à faire des
cérémonies à répéter c'est pas facile ça
commence à venir au fur et à mesure de
de la cohésion d'un groupe aussi la
cohésion du groupe indispensable pour
ces élèves qui seront amenés dans deux
ans a dirigé des équipes de 30 à 40
personnes
la préparation du défilé du 14 juillet
une étape dans leur cursus éducatif à
prendre mieux est donc de faire l'effort
sur eux-mêmes d'être ouverts d'être
comme ils sont actuellement sur cette
belle génération y qui souhaitent
comprendre ce qu'elle fait mais qui est
également apprend à être humble apprend
à obéir aux ordres à donner le meilleur
d'elle-même à s'engager dans l'effort
un engagement que chacun pourra
constater lundi 14 juillet l'occasion du
défilé militaire sur les champs elysées
assurément une grande fierté pour ses
102 élèves de l'école de gendarmerie
c'est vraiment les signes étaient très
connus c'est une grande chance pour nous
de pouvoir le descendre c'est aussi une
façon de réaffirmer notre militarité de
montrer qu'on fait partie de la
communauté militaire donc en tant que
gendarme
on a rarement le lien avec les citoyens
mais
le public donc c'est bien d'avoir ce
retour ce jour là j'espère que qu'on
fera beau et ce 14 juillet jour de fête
nationale que symbolise-t-il pour vous
que représente encore cet événement de
la prise de la bastille c'est notre
question du jour voici vos réponses
c'est un événement c'est la fête
nationale quand même un normalement tous
les gens
font la fête sont heureux il devrait
plus y avoir de conflit c'est une
commémoration de la révolution
la prise de la bastille en 1789 le 14
juillet la fête nationale a fait des
pompiers aller au bal d'un grand théâtre
national
et puis la liberté aussi avec un mari
militaire c'est très important pour moi
j'adore les défilés militaires pour loeb
va au feu d'artifice souvent joueurs une
fête pour plus les français quoi le feu
d'artifice entre 14 juillet toujours et
ce grand concert organisé au champ de
mars à paris actuellement ont supervisé
sur le plan technique par une entreprise
yvelinoise deknight even c'est son nom
est plutôt habitué à organiser des
défilés de haute couture ou encore le
festival des musiques du monde
rabat c'est le premier chantier
d'envergure de cette envergure pour
cette entreprise dans les coulisses avec
le régisseur ces derniers jours mathilde
qu'à berne jonathan vilma année juliette
poussons à moins de quatre jours de la
fête nationale philippe lorriaux
directeur de demnate event entreprises
événementiel yvelinoise n'arrête pas de
courir dans tous les sens régisseur
général du traditionnel concert du 14
juillet au champ de mars de paris son
rôle vérifier si tout se passe
correctement quand m
philippe rey par le plus gros événement
de l'année dans la capitale accroché à
son portable et talkie walkie
il coordonne une vingtaine de sociétés
et supervise à lui seul près de 200
personnes plus les jours passent plus
les imprévus se multiplient est ce que
vous pouvez me renseigner parce qu'en
fait on a trouvé un point d'eau une
fontaine à eau pour alimenter le
quatrième sauf qu'il nous faudrait en
fait une coupure qu'un plombier de la
mairie de paris 1 plombier vient nous
couper en fait la fontaine pour qu'on
puisse se raccorder dessus lundi les
plaques de protection sont à peine
installé deux jours plus tard la scène
est déjà monté depuis trois mois il
enchaîne les rendez-vous et cumulé
dossier l'entreprise yvelinoise a
pourtant déjà organisé le festival des
musiques du monde de rabat mais cette
fois ci c'est particulier si c'est paris
donc on a une pression pas par la ville
de paris à rabat on est au maroc et la
pression elle est moins à l'aise plus
artistique j'ai que par rapport
c'est un des plus gros événements sur
paris donc voilà être la secrétaire
générale de tellement il reste encore
quatre jours à philippe et ses équipes
pour terminer les préparatifs
lundi soir entre 400 et 500 mille
personnes sont attendues sur le champ de
mars un tout autre sujet à présent le
roi du tweet parmi les maires des
yvelines est à chercher du côté de
maurepas à grégory gary astier élu en
mars dernier pour la première fois à 31
ans est en tête du classement et
territoires avec 3591 tweets au 7
juillet il figure à la 44e place au
niveau national
son nom est d'ailleurs félicité
aujourd'hui sur le réseau social
570 mer sont présents sur twitter
toujours selon ce site internet et
territoires la semaine du végétal vient
de se terminer à l'école nationale
supérieure du paysage six pays européens
représentés avec pour objectif d'offrir
à des adultes parfois en difficulté d
apprentissage pour faciliter leur
développement personnel mais également
pour les aider à retrouver le chemin de
l'emploi 150 adultes européens impliqués
dans un projet autour du langage du
végétal parmi leurs réalisations un
livre d exposition et se tapit
transculturelle dévoilé lors du
séminaire de clôture de l'opération
cette semaine à l'école du paysage de
versailles
un projet européen consiste aussi à
partager à communiquer à échanger et le
tapis lui il va symboliser ce dialogue
interculturel que nous essayons de
construire au-delà de la performance le
projet développé devait permettre de
redonner confiance en soi à ses
participants et leur offrir des
perspectives d'emploi grâce à
l'implication de plusieurs partenaires
nous nous sommes un organisme de
formation continue qui forment des
adultes en reconversion pendant deux ans
et donc ce sont des gens qui sont en
totale reconversion qui vont aborder à
nouveau métier mais il ya d'autres
organismes qui sont plutôt des
organismes de formation qui accueille
des personnes qui sont un peu en
difficulté qu'il faut qu'ils vont
approprié une culture une nouvelle
culture
voilà donc cessé quand même des
organismes assez différent mais toujours
axé sur la formation d'adultes cinq
rencontres internationales ont déjà
permis des échanges culturels de ce type
entre différents participants depuis
2012 au portugal en espagne ou encore en
roumanie
nous poursuivons ce journal du 10
juillet toute la semaine l'école
municipale des sports d'elancourt
organise un stage de tennis et
d'athlétisme l'occasion pour les jeunes
de découvrir des disciplines pour
lesquelles ils vont peut-être craqué
pour la rentrée et donc s'inscrire en
club anthony rech
si la tenue de racket est encore
hésitante ces jeunes joueurs découvrent
avec plaisir le tennis j'ai déjà fait
l'année la voile mais je trouve que
c'est mieux de faire du tennis et
l'athlétisme comme ça ça m'apprend
approuvèrent déjà et j'apprends mieux à
taper dans la balle avec une raquette
lors de ce stage de l'école municipale
des sports les courts de tennis c'est
encadré par un professeur de crever dans
courtois l'athlétisme par une éducatrice
de la commune ce n'est pas en une
semaine que l'on devient champion de la
balle jaune
mais au bout de cinq jours de stage
chacun est capable d'être autonome sur
le terrain les tout premiers conseils
cesser d'essayer de faire de jouer en
partenariat parce que tout de suite ils
sont surtout très compétition les
garçons après les filles elles sont
plutôt on ai fait ma copine l'accord
mais alors on essaie de jouer d'abord en
partenariat et puis ensuite pour les
guerres des veillées parce que sinon ils
partent dans tous les sens c'est essayer
de faire des matchs des points des
petits défis
voilà et c'est à l'extérieur l'autre
groupe d'enfants cessé au saut en
longueur
après avoir découvert le lancer ses
jeunes sportifs et 7 toutes les facettes
de l'athlétisme
l'objectif leur donner le goût de
discipline parfois méconnus l'idée c'est
de leur faire découvrir une activité
sportive a donc l'athlétisme
toutes les composantes de l'athlétisme
courses sauts lancers et l'idée c'est de
les initier et puis désintéressé pour
éventuellement plus tard il orienté vers
les clubs
ici il n'y a pas de compétition au
détour de quelques échanges naissent
parfois des amitiés
au total ces 32 enfants bénéficient de
15 heures de sport sur cinq jours pour
seulement 32 euros loisirs jusqu'au 13
juillet le festival remettent et on
propose des ateliers estivaux créatifs
aux petits de magny les hameaux malgré
la pluie olivier maniscalco patrick
jacques de dixmude ont croisé princesses
et autres objets roulants non identifiés
malgré le temps il flotte comme un
parfum de vacances quartier du puits
sont depuis lundi le festival remets tes
tongs propose aux enfants de magny les
hameaux de nombreux ateliers et jeux
aussi sympathique kull dick capoeira
poterie et masques aux instruments
bizarroïde les petits font parler leur
créativité comme ici sur le stand de
fabrication de costumes
elle a dit qu'on ferait un
non je donne des chiffres et après je
crois non loin des princesses un autre
atelier propose de créer son objet
roulant non identifié est déjà un gros
horny orne l'entrée un oiseau tombé de
son lit un gros hormis donc c'est un
perroquet comme on est sur le thème du
brésil on avait choisi de faire un
animal qui est assez représentatif donc
le perroquet donc c'est simple on à
leurs principes partie sur une base à
roulettes on a fixé les arceaux après
par dessus du grillage pour donner forme
et que maintenant on est sur la phase ou
encore là le papier mais les séparent à
l'imagination les laisser travailler
enfin sans donner de directives leur
donner un cadre et puis que derrière ce
cadre puisse s'épanouir comme simplement
pour sa cinquième édition remettait tong
a réuni près de 1000 enfants par jour
samedi un défilé des plus belles
créations se tiendra devant l'estaminet
avant la diffusion dimanche de la finale
du mondial suivie du traditionnel feu
d'artifice merci de nous avoir suivi le
journal revient demain vendredi dernière
édition pour la saison en attendant très
bonne soirée sur tv fil 78 avec clair
qu'en billets pour un nouveau et dernier
numéro de cette année de file echo